[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat et le reportage sur
Public Sénat en étant ensemble du lundi
au jeudi à 18h et 22h pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
et l'événement majeur de ce 8 février
c'est le bilan du tremblement de terre
qui a frappé la Turquie et la Syrie des
vis en volley des chiffres glaçants plus
de 11700 morts en cette fin d'après-midi
de plus en plus d'habitants qui
expriment aussi leur colère notamment
contre le président turc
venait ici il n'y a pas d'aide ici ne te
montre pas comme ça à la télévision ne
passe pas comme ça à la télévision allez
viens je suis là il peut faire ce qu'il
veut de moi il peut faire ce qu'il veut
de moi mais envoie-moi de l'aide ici il
n'y a pas une seule machine
qu'elles peuvent être les conséquences
politiques de ce séisme en Turquie mais
aussi en Syrie comment l'aide
internationale se déploie-t-elle réponse
dans une minute et puis pour notre débat
de société vous le savez volontairement
décalé de l'actualité du jour on va
revenir sur ce constat surprenant et
désespérant de la Haute Autorité à
l'égalité femme homme dans son baromètre
publié le 23 janvier dernier on apprend
que les jeunes de 25 à 34 ans sont plus
sexistes que leurs aînés influence du
porno poids séculaire d'une société
machiste les clichés ont la peau dure
vous verrez
mais d'abord ces femmes ces hommes ses
enfants trop souvent livrés à eux-mêmes
face à ce séisme mesuré à 7,8 sur
l'échelle de Richter images au cœur du
désastre commenté par Hugo Lemonnier
blessé mais vivant dans la province de
haïtaï en Turquie les secours sont à
l'affût du moindre signe de vie de jour
après la catastrophe le conducteur de
l'appelleteuse a crié et immédiatement
on a entendu les voix de trois personnes
nous en attendant d'autres on a de
bonnes chances de retrouver des gens
vivants ici mais le tremblement de terre
de magnitude 7,8 a frappé en pleine nuit
et beaucoup ne se sont jamais réveillés
à gazés en tête la grande ville du sud
du pays les journées sont rythmées par
les funérailles le président
erdouan reconnaît des lacunes dans
l'acheminement de l'aide au rescapés
nous avons eu des problèmes à certains
endroits au début nous avons eu des
problèmes sur les routes mais nous
gérons mieux la situation aujourd'hui et
nous la gérerons encore mieux demain il
y a quelques problèmes mineurs
concernant le carburant nous les
surmontons un par un les autorités
turques comptabilisent 8500 morts à ce
stade mais le bilan ne cesse de
s'alourdir et la colère monte dans les
zones les plus touchées comme ici à
Caraman Maraj près de l'épicentre du
séisme
venez ici il n'y a pas d'aide ici ne te
montre pas comme ça à la télé ne passe
pas comme ça à la télévision moi je suis
l'air douane peut faire ce qu'il veut de
moi il peut faire ce qu'il veut de moi
mais envoyer de l'aide ici il n'y a pas
une seule machine au sud-est de la
Turquie le séisme est venu frapper des
populations déjà fragilisées par la
guerre comme c'est syriens qui avaient
trouvé refuge dans la ville de dire Baki
c'est même pire que la guerre on était
en train de dormir et il est arrivé tout
d'un coup alors que lorsqu'il y a la
guerre on le sait à l'avance on se cache
dans les sous-sols les montagnes ou dans
le désert le tremblement de terre nous a
surpris on n'était pas capable de courir
ou de faire quoi que ce soit on est
juste sorti de l'autre côté de la
frontière en Syrie même image de
désolation le séisme y aurait fait au
moins 2600 morts d'après le décompte des
autorités
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités et chez gulsert bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
indépendante et enseignante à Sciences
Po Georges malbruno bonsoir bienvenue
comment reporter au Figaro spécialiste
du Moyen-Orient et auteur avec Christian
chez nous de ce livre le déclassement
français Élisée Quai d'Orsay DGSE les
secrets d'une guerre d'influence
stratégique livre publié aux Éditions
Michel Lafont Agnès Levallois bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes mes
très de recherche à la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique et j'accueille
Mathieu croissanto bonsoir Mathieu
éditorialiste politique on va évidemment
longuement analyser les les conséquences
politiques de ce séisme chez gulsert
selon l'OMS l'Organisation Mondiale de
la Santé le bilan global pourrait
atteindre les 20000 morts est-ce que ça
vous surprend il y a eu malheureusement
des précédents dans cette dans cette
région et dans ce pays en 99 quand il y
a un tremblement de terre
avec l'épicentre Izmit tout près
d'Istanbul ça avait pris 17000 morts
malheureusement et depuis chaque turc
m'a compris on paye des impôts qui sont
allés pour tout ce qui est construction
reconstruction et
restructuration des bâtiments on voit
bien aujourd'hui qu'on voit 6000
bâtiments qui sont tombés plus de 11700
qui sont morts bon Siri plus Turquie je
pense qu'on va que ça va excéder encore
les 20000 rien n'a été fait et l'une des
questions qu'il est Turcs veulent le
savoir c'est que où et cet argent où
sont partis cet argent et pourquoi les
promesses n'ont pas été tenues vous
voulez dire que déjà parce que là on est
dans le premier temps quel temps de
voilà de du décompte se décompte macabre
on est on imagine la population turque
totalement sonnée parce qu'elle parce
qu'elle subit mais il y a déjà des
questions autour de la corruption parce
que c'est ce que vous nous dites autour
de la corruption autour de là à l'heure
où je vous parle depuis quelques heures
Twitter et absolument l'accès
presque totalement restreint et très
difficile et et ralenti donc ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est ce que les Turcs
voient depuis je dirais une bonne
dizaine d'années c'est-à-dire depuis que
le gouvernement a décidé que tout ce qui
est criticisme tout ce qui est voie
dissidente et quelque chose de personnel
contre la personne d'erdo one ou contre
le régime ce qui n'est pas du tout le
cas là ce qu'on voit c'est encore rien
le nombre de morts ce que nous allons
voir avec l'hypothermie avec les gens
qui étaient dans l'eau il y a plus d'eau
il y a plus de gaz il y a plus
d'électricité les gens ils dorment dans
dans leur dehors ou bien ils dorment
dans leur voiture ça c'est encore les
jolies images que nous voyons
malheureusement dans une semaine on en
reparlerons on a entendu à la fois dans
les titres George malbruno et puis dans
le dans le sujet du golem meunier ce cet
habitant de alors je vais mal prononcer
c'est Karaman Maras merci beaucoup
excusez-moi qui qui apostrophe le
président erdon et qui intègre dans son
apostrophe il dit il peut faire ce qu'il
veut de moi donc il intègre le risque
qu'il prend en s'adressant comme ça au
Président turge je trouve que ce
témoignage il est il est il était
clairant et on parle la Turquie c'est un
grand pays c'est un pays puissant
Erdogan joue souvent de cette fierté
nationale à quel point ça peut le
fragile quand même ça peut le fragiliser
parce que comme ça a été dit
il a lui-même reconnu des des premières
erreurs dans la cheminement de l'aide
des routes qui ont été bloquées
il y a une très grande colère qui
s'exprime aujourd'hui et face à cette
colère on a vu que
Erdogan dans un premier temps
effectivement à reconnu certaines
erreurs mais il a aussi il a aussi
carrément déclaré que ce n'était pas
l'heure des critiques et qu'il fallait
il fallait justement se taire et donc
dans un pays où la critique est de plus
en plus réduite ça peut effectivement
avoir des conséquences on est à 4 mois
ou trois mois et demi des élections
prochaines ça va attendre la situation
il peut y avoir aussi il faut peut-être
un nationaliste aussi ne fait pas dans
quelle mesure ça peut jouer mais au jour
d'aujourd'hui on a vu d'ailleurs je
crois le chef d'opposition qui hier a
dit ça n'est pas le moment de critiquer
on est on est actuellement dans le dans
le chagrin dans la douleur mais
aujourd'hui il commence déjà à critiquer
Erdogan donc oui le président Erdogan va
être placé devant des moments assez
difficiles Agnès comment vous vous
analysez ce que ce que nous disait chez
ulsert c'est à dire le fait que Twitter
soit
restreint voir fermer c'est nos
confrères de l'agence Françoise qui
disent sur fond de critiques exprimées
contre le régime comment vous analysez
on pourrait dire c'est une sorte de
panique un peu de de la part du régime
contrôle les réseaux et donc il voit
bien qu'il a tout à fait intérêt à
essayer de limiter les critiques qui
commencent à s'exprimer je pense qu'il
ne devait pas s'attendre à ce que les
critiques arrivent aussi vite justement
face à l'ampleur de ce dégât à l'ampleur
de ce drame vécu je pense qu'il doit
être le premier surpris de voir de
lecture commence déjà à le critiquer
alors que l'heure est véritablement à la
réaction qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire comme on peut le faire
mais de voir que l'État qui est quand
même un État fort en Turquie à la
différence de ce qui peut se passer en
Syrie et de voir que cet état
effectivement est défaillant dans la
façon qu'il a d'apporter de l'aide les
premiers secours à la population suscite
de la critique et donc face à ça il
prend tous les moyens à sa disposition
pour essayer de limiter justement la
diffusion de ces critiques qui lui font
mal d'autant plus qu'il est à un moment
où il a tout mis en oeuvre pour
faciliter sa réélection même c'est bien
trop tôt pour parler de cet aspect là
mais je pense que ça l'a complètement
fauché et donc il essaye de reprendre la
main et de faire en sorte que ces
critiques ne circulent pas trop on
reparlera du calendrier des élections
dans un instant Mathieu juste pour
comprendre parce que c'est une zone
sismique bien connue est-ce qu'il y a
une culture du tremblement de terre
comme au Japon par exemple que ce soit
dans la population mais aussi des
infrastructures de l'État dont vous
parliez je souris parce que c'est
tellement beau et logique la question
que vous posez c'est tellement illogique
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui en Turquie
c'est-à-dire que
il devrait y avoir il y a eu moi ma mère
il est dans une région de l'Anatolie qui
s'appelle alzin qui n'est pas très loin
de de cette région ou en 1939 il y a eu
plus de 30 mille morts je viens de
parler de
99 on a eu des séismes on a eu des after
choc qui continue actuellement donc
normalement des répliques merci
et donc normalement il devrait y avoir
aujourd'hui il y a même des des secours
japonais qui sont sur place et qui qui
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il revienne
après 99 et qui doivent être horrifiées
de voir que ce gouvernement que ce pays
sachant géographiquement les risques qui
courent qui n'ont absolument rien fait
et non seulement ils n'ont rien fait ils
ont laissé faire je veux dire quoi en
disant le laisser faire c'est laisser
les architectes c'est laisser les
contrats les codes pour que ça passe
pour je vote pour toi je te donne les
permis etc c'est exactement ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui ici je peux me
permettre de dire c'est vrai que ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui Twitter c'est pas
juste une question de critique
aujourd'hui les dans les 48 heures là où
nous sommes en train de lire dans les 72
heures les Twitter est utilisé comme une
façon pour le population de dire j'ai de
la famille à cette adresse il y a 12
personnes dans ce bâtiment de quatre
étages allez voir ce qu'il y a nous
n'avons pas ou bien de dire dans cette
province nous avons besoin de tentes de
nourriture etc donc c'est vraiment
l'information de vie et de morts qui
sont en train aujourd'hui de
sur laquelle ils sont en train de mettre
un rideau de fin 90% des rescapés sont
secourus dans les 72 heures qui suivent
un séisme une catastrophe comme celle-là
donc effectivement un réseau comme
social comme Twitter c'est un outil de
de sauvetage tout simplement dont voilà
ça va être compliqué de de faire peu
porter la responsabilité
aussi vite ce soir sur le régime mais
bon c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on peut
comprendre donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que là aussi si on essaye de
moi je connais évidemment beaucoup moins
la Turquie que que vous mais il y a un
poids
politique qui peut payer le poids de ses
décisions Erdogan est-ce que vous diriez
ça oui ce qui est clair quand même c'est
que toutes les mesures qui avaient été
promises au lendemain justement du
tremblement de terre de 1999 avec ce
fameux impôt qui a été apposé à la
population pour prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour éviter que un tel drame
ne se reproduise puisque l'on sait il y
a des sismologues qui lui disent depuis
maintenant des années que tout le monde
s'attend à une catastrophe énorme à
Istanbul même puisque la deuxième ville
importante du pays et se trouve sur une
zone qui est éminemment dangereuse tout
le monde sait
istanbulent aujourd'hui il doit y avoir
quoi plus de 10000 ans mais moi je pense
toujours que quand on dit en Turquie 12
millions ça doit être 15 millions
d'accord et donc on voit bien que toutes
les mesures qui avaient été promises
n'ont pas été mises en oeuvre parce
qu'il y a une économie informelle énorme
et que donc il y a tout un trafic qui se
passe à travers les compagnies de BTP de
bâtiments publics pour la construction
que toutes les normes qui normalement
devrait être imposées n'ont pas été
respectées et ça c'est quelque chose que
l'on voit dans beaucoup de pays pourquoi
au Japon qui est un pays qui soumis à
d'énormes tremblements de terre
lorsqu'il y a tremblement de terre il y
a pratiquement aucune victime parce que
toutes les mesures ont été prises dans
le cas de la construction ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas en Turquie alors
que je le répète c'est important les
promesses avaient été faites et que les
Turcs ont payé de leur poche dans le cas
de cette impose spéciale et que
finalement s'aperçoit que rien n'a été
fait et quand on a regardé les premières
images de ces immeubles entiers qui
tombaient mais comme ça c'était
absolument impressionnant c'était bien
la démonstration que rien n'avait été
mis en oeuvre pour limiter cela je
repose un peu la même question genre
malbonnot pour un pour un récepteur qui
joue de cette fierté nationale du
nationalisme c'est quand même un coup
assez dur porté à un discours à ses
arguments oui c'est un coup très dur
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
allé quand même sur place très
rapidement mais il a essayé de contrer
justement cette vague de critique
montante tout ça s'inscrit sur une toile
de fond de crise économique sévère donc
effectivement pour lui c'est c'est une
très mauvaise nouvelle est-ce que des
pardon de vous interrompre est-ce que
les critiques de corruption convient
d'évoquer ici est-ce que elles peuvent
s'exprimer dans les médias turcs quel
est le degré de liberté des médiatures
pour pour voilà mener ces enquêtes et
les et les partager la Turquie plus la
Syrie mais de moins en moins j'ai
l'impression
des médias sont sous le goût ce sont des
partisans du régime donc il faut faire
passer l'information ça limite
considérablement les enquêtes après on
sait que la Turquie ces dernières années
a considérablement resserré le contrôle
sur la presse donc
il y a un parallèle vous avez commencé à
le faire mais il y a un parallèle
politique qu'on peut faire entre 99 et
aujourd'hui parce que qu'est-ce qui se
passe politiquement dans la foulée du
tremblement de terre de 1999 oui et ça
revient à une question que vous avez
posé tout à l'heure aussi auquel j'ai
pas pu répondre c'est-à-dire que c'est
vrai qu'on ne peut pas tout mettre sur
ce gouvernement parce que les
gouvernements avant n'ont pas fait leur
travail non plus c'est-à-dire que moi je
me souviens très bien au début des
années 2000 la raison pour laquelle le
hackp party donc le parti politique de
le Jedi a été à a été victorieux dans
les élections pourtant c'était un parti
politique qui n'était pas du tout connu
à l'époque
dans les gens réclamés 1 ils avaient vu
exactement les mêmes images qu'on voit
aujourd'hui qu'il y a similaire en 99 et
lisait non ce gouvernement ne prendra
pas pas soin de nous et la deuxième
chose c'était la crise économique moi je
dis que erdoğan et son parti politique
est venu au début des années 2000 à
cause d'un tremblement de terre et une
crise financière aujourd'hui en 2023 si
les élections se font au mois de mai
ils partira normalement logiquement à
cause d'un tremblement de terre et une
crise économique malbonnot est-ce que
vous êtes aussi affirmatif c'est
difficile parce que non parce que des
prévisions
sur ce plateau oui vous avez
probablement raison mais mais on est
face à un homme
extraordinaire dans le propre projet
absolument capable de de procéder à des
revirements de situation on en parlera
et ses réconcilier avec ses ennemis
arabes donc voilà
Erdogan je sais pas s'il va gagner ou
perdre mais en tout cas il va utiliser
tous les moyens qui sont à sa
disposition pour garder son pouvoir la
crise économique quand même c'est
effectivement une des éléments de
l'équation qui est intéressant
Agnès Levallois ça complique le la
réponse de du régime et de et de
d'Erdogan aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
la crise économique quand même atteint
tous les Turcs et donc un drame comme
celui-ci en plus d'une situation où une
inflation absolument démesurée ou le
prix de l'essence est absolument insensé
à une période de l'année quand même où
les conditions météorologiques et ça je
pense qu'il est important de le rappeler
ils sont quand même extrêmement
difficiles c'est une région où il neige
il fait froid et donc il y a des besoins
encore plus importants pour la
population qui se trouve dans la rue
donc on va mettre en place des systèmes
de tente chauffer pour sauver ou en tous
les cas permettre de aux populations de
vivre en attendant la reconstruction et
donc tout ça va s'ajouter quand même aux
difficultés économiques que traverse la
Turquie aujourd'hui et donc va accroître
me semble-t-il dans tous les les
difficultés des Turcs et éventuellement
les réactions de ceci fassent à ce
gouvernement alors là pour le coup
évidemment le gouvernement n'est pas
responsable de ce tremblement de terre
mais ça arrive à un moment pour lui en
tous les cas qui risque de le mettre
encore plus en difficulté sans tirer
plus de plans sur la comète mais on peut
simplement dire ça sans prendre aucun
risque que ça va accroître et du coup
accroître le ressentiment des Turcs par
rapport à la gestion de cette après
tremblement de terre surtout que on l'a
évoqué il y a ces élections qui se
profilent elles sont prévues l'élection
présidentielle et législatives le 14 mai
prochain ils égoutsèrent elles étaient
initialement prévues en juin c'est ça
pourquoi Erdogan les a les a avancés
c'est quoi la stratégie du président
turc un peu ce que George malbruno
disait c'est-à-dire que c'est un animal
politique tellement extraordinaire
extraordinaire entre guillemets que ils
doivent bien y avoir une raison la
raison là je pense qu'il y en a
plusieurs un dans un mois si le ramadan
ce gouvernement a toujours voulu de
créer une génération pieuse de de on a
sens d'acheter les votes en donnant à
manger en donnant de des facilités et
c'est comme on l'a vu aussi avec
Sainte-Sophie la basilique qui était
pendant plus de 80 ans une amusée et qui
est devenu une mosquée depuis l'été 2020
qui a Istanbul et qui sublime et donc il
utilise tout à son avantage donc il va
utiliser le ramadan pour dire votre père
parce que les Turcs on cherche un père
nous sommes éperdument à la recherche
d'un père ça a été le cas avec atatür et
c'est le cas avec les JEPS donc le père
va vous donner à nourrir le père prendra
soin de vous et et donc je pense qu'il
va utiliser ça un deuxièmement le mois
de mai c'est les 10 ans des
manifestations du guezi de 2013 dont je
suis sûre que vous vous souvenez donc je
pense qu'il va utiliser cette situation
pour dire que s'il y a des émeutes des
manifestations que ce n'est pas parce
que le la veine et le mécontentement le
deezi est toujours en vie mais c'est
parce que les gens ne sont pas contents
de ce qui se passe avec les élections il
veut brouiller les pistes et je pense
que c'est la raison pour laquelle il a
décidé de le faire à moi plus tôt son
raisonnement c'est au mois de juin il
fait très chaud il y a les vacances donc
je pense à vous les examens
universitaires donc je pense à vous on
va le faire à moi plus tôt est-ce qu'il
peut encore changer les dates le
président
ça risque d'être un peu compliqué de de
changer à nouveau mais on voit bien
qu'il est dans une logique où il est il
a essayé finalement je pense aussi pour
ajouter un point s'il a essayé de
profiter d'une dynamique dans laquelle
il pensait une dynamique favorable pour
lui dans le cas de la guerre en Ukraine
avec cette espèce d'équilibre qu'il a
réussi à maintenir entre d'un côté son
alliance dans l'OTAN mais également ses
relations privilégiées avec la Russie la
façon qu'il a eu aussi de reprendre des
relations avec beaucoup de pays de la
région les pays du Golfe en particulier
mais aussi avec Israël et donc il donne
le sentiment d'avoir une dynamique
favorable en politique régionale et
internationale où il arrive à être
vraiment un acteur incontournable qui
parle pratiquement avec tout le monde
finalement dans la région ce qui n'est
pas le cas de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et donc je pense qu'il a voulu
aussi capitaliser sur cette image qui
donne au turc et qui est appréciée par
les Turcs de montrer que lui est capable
de parler aussi bien avec Poutine
qu'avec Biden qu'avec les Européens mais
qu'avec le roi le prince héritier en
Arabie Saoudite avec et donc je pense
que c'est ça aussi qui l'a incité
finalement à profiter de cette dynamique
qui était perçue comme telle pour lui en
tous les cas est-ce qu'il y a une
opposition crédible et une alternative
possible il y a toujours une opposition
il y a on le voit aujourd'hui que ça
soit on parlait au début de l'émission
de Twitter des réseaux sociaux il y a
des journalistes qui ont été limogés et
qui n'arrivent pas à trouver un travail
qui quand même à travers l'Internet sont
sur le terrain essaye de d'expliquer au
peuple qui utilise parfois des VPN afin
d'avoir accès à tout ça l'opposition est
là mais le problème qu'il y a c'est que
l'opposition est position politique dans
le cadre d'élection
politique est là mais n'est pas forte
elle n'est pas une idée déjà il y a un
maire d'Istanbul qui normalement aurait
remporté qui à cause des manœuvres de du
du Grand sultan n'y arriverez pas en
utilisant parce qu'il y a plus d'état de
droits en Turquie qui l'opposition
politique aujourd'hui essaye aussi je
pense à un niveau pas très élégant mais
à leur manière d'utiliser ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui pour dire regarder ce
gouvernement ne fait plus rien pour vous
mais nous on est là
et donc c'est là mais ça va pas être
facile parce qu'il ne faut pas oublier
que à chaque sélection
erdouane et le gouvernement ils font de
leur mieux afin de limiter l'accès
pendant les campagnes à la télévision à
la radio des oppositions c'est à dire
que ce qu'on envoie et on entend quand
même comme voie unique c'est celui du
gouvernement alors il y a on va on va
parler de la diplomatie du séisme parce
que c'est vraiment il faut dire ça ça
peut sembler un peu cynique mais c'est
une réalité on va appeler Steve Jourdain
nous rejoindre pour parler de l'aide
internationale mais d'abord je vous
propose d'écouter le porte-parole de
l'Agence humanitaire des Nations Unies
il appelle les pays à aider la Turquie
et la Syrie sans politique
le premier effort est vraiment la
recherche et le sauvetage il y a une
fenêtre d'environ 7 jours c'est ce que
l'expérience nous dit où nous trouverons
des survivants vivants cela peut arriver
plus tard mais il est vraiment essentiel
que ces équipes se rendent sur place dès
que possible
il est impératif que tout le monde
considère cette situation comme
humanitaire pour ce qu'elle est
une crise humanitaire ou des vies sont
en jeu s'il vous plaît ne politisez pas
tout cela acheminons l'aide aux
personnes qui en ont si désespérément
besoin
si le jour d'un bonsoir bienvenue à vous
l'aide internationale qui a commencé à
arriver hier en Turquie il y a donc une
géopolitique du soutien au sinistre
alors il faut effectivement distinguer
la Turquie et la Syrie pour la Turquie
si l'on en croit le président herdoine
45 pays ont déjà proposé leur aide au
total cela représente
3294 volontaires et 9 chiens de
recherche selon les autorités turques
côté français 139 secouristes pompiers
et membres de la sécurité civile ont été
mobilisés cet après-midi au Sénat
Elizabeth borne est revenu sur la
politique de la France envers en carats
et lundi le président de la République a
annoncé la mobilisation de notre pays
est proposée une aide d'urgence des
sapeurs-pompiers des sapeurs sauveteurs
et des personnels du centre de crise et
de soutien sont arrivés sur place ils
contribuent aux recherches sur le
terrain qui est intéressant c'est se
pencher sur les pays qui apportent leur
assistance parmi eux l'Union européenne
les pays du Golfe les États-Unis la
Chine ou encore la Grèce la Grèce pays
voisins et rivale historique de la
Turquie ces derniers mois les tensions
entre les deux pays étaient extrêmement
fortes autour notamment des questions
migratoires et des questions
énergétiques on évoquait même des
risques de conflits militaires directs
le séisme est peut-être en train de
faire légèrement redescendre la pression
nous devons mettre toutes les forces
disponibles à la disposition de la
Turquie c'était une via ça j'étais sous
le Kiya le ramadan
de terre catastrophique dont on ne
mesure pas toute l'ampleur il y a que tu
achètes
a décidé d'envoyer de l'aide d'une
centaine de secouristes vont être
dépêchés en Turquie la Turquie qui
fournit des drones acquieve dans la
guerre contre la Russie et qui je joue
un rôle important dans la médiation avec
Moscou et maintenant qu'en est-il de la
Syrie tableau très différent pour la
Syrie pour bien comprendre on va avoir
une carte le séisme à frapper le nord du
pays or si on exclut la ville d'aleps
toutes les zones de la région échappent
à Bachar el-Assad on voit la Provence la
province deadlib ou les localités sont
contrôlés par des djihadistes par des
supplétifs turques ou encore par des
Kurdes il existe aujourd'hui un seul
point de passage entre la Syrie et la
Turquie le point de passage de babalawa
mais ce corridor est aujourd'hui
impraticable il a été touché lui aussi
par le tremblement de terre ce qui va
compliquer la cheminement de l'aide dans
cette région syrienne une région qui
compte plus de 4 millions 500 000
habitants pour l'instant parmi les pays
qui ont proposé leur aide à la Syrie on
trouve notamment la Russie évidemment
elle l'Iran Israël qui est un pays
ennemi et qui a proposé son aide la
Chine elle aussi annoncée qu'elle allait
débloquée plusieurs millions de dollars
pour soutenir la Syrie on le voit Thomas
l'aide internationale permis de venir en
aide au sinistre évidemment et ça permet
aussi de faire de la diplomatie merci
beaucoup Steve Jourdain pour toutes ces
informations on reparlera de la Syrie on
va vraiment y consacrer du temps un peu
plus tard mais peut-être sur la Turquie
un mot George balbruno est-ce que
l'aide international on a vu que la
France avait envoyé un certain nombre de
de secouriste ça peut assouplir adoucir
les relations entre Emmanuel Macron et
le président turc
oui ça peut contribuer à adoucir un
petit peu mais on est quand même j'ai
l'impression retomber un petit peu dans
cette il y a eu un moment de forte
tension en 2019 notamment sur la Libye
on avait des positions diamétralement
opposées il y a eu presque une attaque
turque contre un bateau français en
suite il a fallu Emmanuel Macron
reconnaître le rôle d'Erdogan dans le
conflit Russo ukrainien et je crois que
je crois que la Turquie effectivement
Erdogan si il est fortement contesté
chez lui et il a réussi au plan
extérieur à apparaître comme un
acteur incontournable tu l'as dit avec
les pays arabes avec lesquels il était
en grande conflit l'Arabie Saoudite les
Émirats et l'Egypte il s'est réconcilié
en partie partie pour bénéficier des
investissements de ces pays-là parce que
justement il est confronté à une crise
économique importante avec Israël aussi
la tournée la page
un médiateur entre Russes et ukrainien
et il est on y reviendra il a changé de
biais vis-à-vis de son ennemi Bachar
el-Assad avec lequel il a engagé des
négociations qui risquent de de comment
dirais-je de reconfigurer
définitivement ce qui reste un petit peu
de ce de cette de cette à la fois de
cette opposition syrienne et de ce
conflit c'est rien donc voilà après
Emmanuel Macron et
les irritants sont quand même beaucoup
moins nombreux maintenant entre entre
deux personnes qui étaient d'ailleurs un
caractère un petit peu semblable assez
assez sanguin assez et donc qui s'était
affronté mais aujourd'hui on est on est
retombé un petit peu dans cette leçon
était monté très haut quand même
mis en cause la santé mentale du
président de la République on se
souvient que parmi les pierres
d'achauffement il y avait la question de
la Méditerranée orientale notamment et
du conflit avec la Grèce et puis il y
avait aussi la loi séparatisme qui avait
beaucoup irrité la loi portée en France
sur les principes républicains là qui
avait beaucoup énervé excité la Turquie
il y a la communauté turque en France
qui est considérée comme un relais
effectivement de la souvent de la capé
ou du ou des Erdogan et qui s'en était
servis pour justement attiser les
braises on prie dans la faire Samuel
pati et autres on avait il y avait une
posture turque qui n'avait pas plus du
tout à l'Élysée Agnès on l'a évoqué avec
Steve Jourdain cette aide internationale
elle reflète aussi les rapports de force
complètement on voit bien que dans ces
cas là il y a des pays qui veulent
apporter leur aide pour montrer qu'ils
sont eux en mesure de le faire et donc
c'est toujours difficile aussi pour les
pics en ont besoin d'accepter parce que
c'est reconnaître aussi une faiblesse et
en tout cas des besoins alors là le
drame est tel qui évidemment la Turquie
ne peut qu'accepter cette aide mais on
voit bien ce que ça veut dire de ces
rapports de force et quand on dit qu'en
Syrie les deux pays qui ont répondu tout
au début c'est la Russie l'Iran ce sont
les deux soutiens de pacha al-Assad plus
la Chine et puis Israël qui joue soit
parti comme à chaque fois de dire on va
on va présenter une aide et Bachar
al-Assad qui dit mais j'ai rien rien
reçu comme offre et il est hors de
question d'accepter quoi que ce soit
donc évidemment on est dans un dans un
domaine qui est éminemment politique
comment il est perçue cette aide
international et notamment l'aide de la
France
là au stade où on est tout est bienvenu
c'est
intéressant parce qu'on dit on ne peut
pas politiser moi je peux dire que en
Turquie tout est politisé et ça a
toujours été le cas que ça soit un match
de football un séisme des élections tout
est politique en Turquie c'est ça qui a
comme comme fibre qui fait qui fait
vibrer autour après c'est vrai que
erdoan ou bien disons le lit le
président de ce grand pays de 85
millions de personnes
a été un peu comme un caméléon dans les
dernières années c'est-à-dire que oui
d'un côté il a parlé de mort cérébrale
en 2019 envers Emmanuel Macron que vous
évoquiez d'un autre côté avec les
États-Unis qui a été un allié pendant
très longtemps là il accepte aussi
l'aide qui vient donc même s'il s'est
rapproché il faut pas oublier des pays
arabes il s'est éloigné de de ces pays
comme les États-Unis comme l'Union
européenne on parlons même pas du rêve
européen d'un jour d'en faire partie qui
est très très très très au loin et donc
ça a été peut-être un gain du côté des
relations arabes mais ça a été une perte
du côté des relations occidentaux et
Agnès sur les relations on a entendu le
Premier ministre grec proposait son aide
entre deux voisins
Oni alors moi je veux pas non plus
surestimer le les conséquences d'un
séisme comme celui-là mais qu'est-ce que
ça peut provoquer moi je ne crois pas
que ça puisse changer fondamentalement
les relations c'est-à-dire que dans un
moment comme celui-ci il y a la première
réaction et chacun se doit d'être humain
simplement et donc votre voisin subit un
tel drame vous allez offrir votre aide
parce que c'est tout à fait naturel et
si vous accepte après une autre question
c'est une autre question et donc vous
pouvez vous pouvez qu'apparaître comme
étant venant au secours de votre voisin
est-ce que ça va changer et ça va
permettre de restaurer la confiance qui
a été perdue entre les deux pays je
pense que là il faut être beaucoup plus
prudent là on est dans l'émotion on est
dans l'urgence et toutes les aides sont
absolument indispensables en plus la
Turquie la Grèce peut se dire qu'un jour
s'élever elle vit la même chose elle
peut avoir besoin d'une aide et donc il
faut aussi être vigilant aux relations
qu'on a en particulier avec nos voisins
alors on va faire maintenant un gros
plan sur la situation en Syrie c'est
évidemment plus difficile d'avoir des
images et un bilan précis payés et en
guerre je vous propose pour commencer
d'entendre ce témoignage un homme qui
s'appelle Hassan qui est habitant de
John dayiris sa ville et dévastée
le séisme a détruit 80% de la ville même
les bâtiments qui ne se sont pas
effondrés ont été gravement endommagés
il y a maintenant plus de personnes sous
les décombres que c'est le dessus il y a
environ 4 à 500 personnes piégées sous
chaque bâtiment effondré avec seulement
10 personnes essayant de les sortir et
il n'y a pas de machine
George mal Bruno on parlait quasiment
plus de la Syrie depuis des semaines
depuis des mois quelle est la situation
c'est encore un pays en guerre avant ce
séisme quelle était la situation non
c'est un pays qui n'est plus en guerre
en tout cas d'une guerre de haute
intensité après
12 années de conflit entre les opposants
à Bachar al-Assad et le régime syrien
bon le régime syrien a sauvé sa peau
Bachar al-Assad a sauvé sa peau il règne
sur un pays qui est en large partie en
ruine il a recouvré une partie de la
souveraineté sur ce pays sauf dans cette
région deleb qui était en rouge sur
votre carte qui est aujourd'hui la
principale région syrienne touchait
justement par ce tremblement de terre il
y a aussi les régions d'Alep et un
jusqu'à ama au sud qui sont sous
contrôle si rien gouvernemental qui ont
été touchés mais les deux tiers je pense
on est à combien 3000 morts je crois
côté syrien sont dans la région dedleb
qui est une poche au nord-ouest de la
Syrie qui est la dernière région qui
échappe si on accepte les Kurdes au
nord-est qui a une relation avec Bachar
el-Assad quand même c'est la dernière
région Nord-Ouest a échappé au contrôle
de Bachar el-Assad où ont été je dirais
envoyés tous les tous les tous les
rebelles dont on voulait pas et en
particulier djihadistes et le seul point
de passage c'est la Turquie c'est
rebelle djihadistes islamistes etc les
services de renseignement turc les
contrôles et il y a un point de passage
babelawa etc on a vu qui a été en grande
partie détruit en grande partie détruit
et donc aujourd'hui je retrouve là il se
retrouve sous les décombres on a vu des
scènes absolument horribles et avec donc
une absence d'aide humanitaire ou très
très faible et puis des pays des pays
occidentaux qui ne occidentaux je dis
bien européen en particulier américain
qui ne veulent pas faire passer de
l'aide par Damas parce que Bachar
el-Assad on y reviendra dit bah oui il
faut faire passer de l'aide par la masse
mais c'est moi qui la gère après donc
risque de la dévier de là où elle doit
aller et puis voilà donc c'est une
situation extrêmement compliquée mais il
y a une très très grande urgence
humanitaire on a vu des images
absolument horribles et donc donc voilà
donc ça alors là pour le coup en Syrie
on est sur le on est sur on y reviendra
probablement avec la France qui essaie
probablement de profiter de cette crise
on y reviendrait il y a une politisation
de l'aide parce que pour le régime de
Bachar el-Assad ça va être l'occasion
effectivement et bien qu'on renoue sans
renouer quoi mais dire je suis
incontournable la Syrie c'est moi il
faut aider c'est une question
humanitaire lorsque le responsable des
Nations Unies dites il ne faut pas
politiser l'aide il a peut-être en tête
dire il faut il faut aussi aider la
Syrie c'est ce qu'on entendait entre les
lignes quoi voilà et donc effectivement
il y a des Syriens rebelles qui ont
besoin d'aide mais aussi des Syriens
probachs en tout cas qui vivent dans les
zones qui ont besoin d'aide donc comment
les aider c'est toute la question
je voudrais juste ajouter c'est que
avant le séisme doute l'aide humanitaire
pour la région de Hitler cette fameuse
zone qui échappe complètement contrôle
le Bachar el-Assad passé par bellawa
donc ce passage avec la Turquie et qui
était négocié tous les six mois par la
Russie ou dans le cadre du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU et avec à chaque fois
la Russie qui essayait de de faire
admettre à la communauté internationale
de changer de points d'appui et de
passer par un point contrôlé par le
régime parce que bah la loi échapper au
contrôle et donc les humanitaires eux
voulaient un passage renouveler tous les
ans pour vraiment laisser le temps à
s'organiser et les Russes à chaque fois
négocie et c'est de six mois en six mois
et ça venait d'être renouvelé en janvier
pour permettre cette aide humanitaire de
passer parce que déjà en temps normal
cette zone n'avait absolument rien donc
là l'aide humanitaire devrait pouvoir
continuer à passer par babalawa sauf que
le point de passage apparemment a été
détruit par le par le tremblement de
terre et donc la situation aujourd'hui à
idly vous avez simplement ce qu'on
appelle les casques blancs qui sont la
force de protection civile composée
simplement de bénévoles de citoyens qui
s'organisent déjà depuis des années
depuis qu'il y a des bombardements sur
cette zone et qui s'organise dès qu'il y
a un bombardement par le régime par la
Russie pour sauver les Syriens qui sont
dans des découpes donc il y a une
certaine expertise malheureusement si je
puis dire et qui se retrouve là en
première ligne parce qu'il n'y a
personne d'autre qui peut apporter du
soutien parce que c'est une zone dans
laquelle le régime ne rentre pas c'est
vraiment une enclave complètement coupée
du reste du monde et c'est là où c'est
dramatique parce que cet enclave ne vit
que grâce à l'aide d'une humanitaire
depuis maintenant des années mais avec
tous les obstacles aussi qui sont mis
par le régime et par la Russie qui est
le soutien pour limiter pour simplement
permettre une survie mais sûrement pas
plus alors on va évidemment analyser
ensemble les là aussi les conséquences
politiques et diplomatiques pour le
régime de Bachar el-Assad d'abord
Mathieu peut-être un retour sur les
relations entre Emmanuel Macron et le
dictateur syrien oui parce que je lisais
ce matin dans Le Figaro un excellent art
qui évoquait peut-être la possibilité
d'un rapprochement d'un changement
d'approche en tout cas entre entre Paris
et Damas ce qui m'a fait du coup me
pencher un peu sur les relations entre
entre Paris et la masse qui sont quasi
nuls mais sur certains bouger quand même
d'Emmanuel Macron depuis qu'il est
arrivé à l'Élysée en 2017 il y a eu
différentes différentes approches quand
nous approches en tout cas différents
vocabulaire différent en 2017 de ces
premières déclarations c'est en marge de
l'Assemblée Générale des Nations des
Nations Unies et là il s'inscrit
Emmanuel Macron dans la droite ligne de
son prédécesseur François Hollande
Bachar al-Assad est un criminel il
devrait être jugé et répondre de ses
crimes devant la justice internationale
dit-il mais à l'inverse du pouvoir
socialiste qui répétait comme un mantra
vous souvenez de Laurent Fabius Bachard
doit partir bachel doit partir et ben
Emmanuel Macron dit qu'il ne fait pas de
la destitution de Bachar el-Assad un
préalable par pragmatisme parce qu'au
fond il fait ça depuis le début et ça ne
sert à rien bon ça pas de quoi
réchauffer les relations entre les deux
hommes puisque on rappelle que de toute
façon Paris avait rappelé son
ambassadeur des 2012 voilà et fin 2017
Bachar al-Assad lui accuse les Français
dans une grande diatrie d'avoir les
mains tachées du sang des Syriens parce
qu'ils se seraient fait les portes
étendard du soutien en terrorisme en
Syrie en fait c'est une référence
évidemment au soutien apporté par Paris
ou rebelles depuis le début du conflit
et mano Macron juge ses propos
inacceptables alors 2018-2018 la France
avec les États-Unis et le Royaume-Uni
vont souvenir lance des frappes contre
des sites de production d'armes
chimiques après des attaques du régime
contre des civils des attaques chimiques
à Douma mais la France n'a pas déclaré
la guerre au régime de Bachar el-Assad
précise aussitôt le chef de l'État qui
lancera parallèlement pour l'anecdote
mais quand même une procédure pour
retirer la Légion d'Honneur parce que
Bachar el-Assad avait été décoré Grand
Croix la Légion d'honneur par Jacques
Chirac en 2001 en août 2018 toujours
nouveau bouger alors là c'est devant les
ambassadeurs et les ambassadrices le
maintien au pouvoir du président syrien
Bachar el-Assad serait funeste di
Emmanuel Macron donc on revient à ce
moment-là un petit peu à la position
précédente et en fait il précise que la
position de la France c'est quand même
de tout faire pour qu'il y ait un
processus de transition démocratique qui
puisse installer quelque chose et puis
2021 3 ans plus tard nouveau bouger là
on est au moment de la chute de daesh et
Madame Macron à la télévision explique
que Bachar el l'ennemi du peuple syrien
mais que son ennemi à lui c'est daech et
puis il dit Bachar el-Assad sera là car
il est protégé par ceux qui sur le
terrain ont gagné la guerre que ce soit
l'Iran la Russie donc il faudra parler à
Bachar et assez représentants et
peut-être qu'on en est encore là
aujourd'hui si je peux me permettre
exactement c'est un très bon rappel vous
oubliez simplement une déclaration
d'Emmanuel Macron en juillet 2017
lorsqu'il vient d'être élu il dit Bachar
el-Assad et l'ennemi des Syriens il
n'est pas l'ennemi de la France et donc
là on se dit Emmanuel Macron pragmatique
lui il hérite d'une situation il n'y a
pour rien il va
opérer peut-être un pas réel politique
ou je ne sais pas rapprochement avec
avec la Syrie ce qui s'est passé ensuite
c'est qu'il y a eu une montée au créneau
d'un certain nombre de d'anciens
diplomates etc de Français qui sont
allés à l'Élysée qui ont dit comment ça
etc et donc ensuite Emmanuel Macron a
fait un pas en arrière ensuite a fait un
pas en avant ensuite a fait un pas en
arrière et là ce que vous racontez-nous
parfois on sont allés voir etc parce
qu'on a 130 djihadistes à Idleb qui sont
là-bas donc est-ce que vous racontez
pendant des interrompre dans l'article
alors dans quelle matière référence
c'est c'est un nouveau bouger pour
reprendre votre terminologie il y a
maintenant une évolution c'est que par
rapport à 2018-2019 le processus de
transition met en place par les Nations
Unies n'avance pas parce que le régime
en particulier le paquet d'avance il a
gagné donc il va faire aucune concession
donc on oublie ça ensuite vous avez un
syndrome de pays arabes en particulier
générale Arabes Unis qui sont l'Allier
principal d'Emmanuel Macron Mohamed
benzaie pédalier principal d'Emmanuel
Macron vous avez aussi l'Egypte ici qui
est aussi un proche allié d'Emmanuel
Macron l'Arabie Saoudite la Jordanie etc
ont tous renoué avec la Syrie non pas
par amour pour Bachar el-Assad mais pas
Réal politique il y a des problèmes de
réfugiés les problèmes de terroristes et
puis parce que on est réalise parce que
Bachar el-Assad ne partira pas du
pouvoir et donc lorsque vous dites la
France peut pas rater ce train c'est la
question qui se pose quoi Emmanuel
Macron me l'a dit la semaine dernière
avant le séisme quelqu'un qui est proche
Emmanuel Macron probablement poussé
notamment par Mohamed benzaieb et si si
et d'autres se dit il y a un mouvement
de réhabilitation du président syrien
qui est opéré etc par le monde arabe la
Turquie l'ennemi juré
Erdogan de Bachar el-Assad a engagé des
négociations et ben pour pour renouer
pour renouer et donc si jamais c'est
négociations aboutissent ça veut dire
que en grande partie nos alliés kurdes
vont être obligés de renouer avec Bachar
et que les forces américaines pour le
monde vont partir par conséquent
Emmanuel Macron se dit il va se passer
quelque chose et comme Emmanuel Macron à
l'ambition il l'a montré en décembre
encore lorsqu'il est allé en Jordanie
qu'il a réuni un salon de pays arabe sur
l'Irak il veut jouer un rôle d'acteurs
entre ces différents pays et il l'a dit
aussi après il dit sur le Liban il faut
essayer de de faire quelque chose un peu
sur ce même format donc si vous voulez
sur le Liban donc ça veut dire Siri donc
ça veut dire moi je veux pas être absent
de ce traitant et donc effectivement il
y a une réflexion alors les conseillers
les manuel Macron sont loin d'être tous
sur la même longueur d'onde et en faveur
de ça parce que a été dépeint comme le
nouvel Hitler donc ça va être compliqué
mais par souci de Réal politique ou
parce que parce que si vous voulez il se
dit il se dit si je veux jouer un rôle
au Moyen-Orient et bien la Syrie est
incontournable donc il y a cette
évolution ce qui est important ça c'est
avant avant le tremblement de terre je
pense que le tremblement de terre
peut permettre à la France
de revenir sans le dire sans forcément
renouer avec Bachar al-Assad mais sous
couvert d'humanitaire à petit pas sans
que ça déclenche d'un tolé de la part de
effectivement de tous ceux ils sont
nombreux qui réclament que Bacha Assad
soit jugé pour ses crimes un mode
conclusion sur ce thème il y a plusieurs
aspects c'est-à-dire que il y a tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord au sein de la
diplomatie en France sur cette question
il y a quand même des tenants au Quai
d'Orsay en particulier qui estiment que
aucune des conditions n'est réunies pour
que la France puisse renouer avec la
Syrie que Bachar el-Assad n'a pas changé
moi je dirais pas qu'il a gagné il a
repris le contrôle du territoire mais il
a gagné sur un voilà sur un champ de
ruine et donc il y a vraiment des débats
très forts dans la au sein de Massy pour
savoir quoi faire mais l'idée principale
c'est de dire que rien n'a changé de la
part de ce régime et donc il y a aucune
raison de changer nous notre politique
et que tout ça va s'inscrire je pense
aussi dans une politique européenne
puisque c'est une politique européenne
qui a déterminé les sanctions qui
s'imposent à la et le fait que on ne
puisse pas normaliser et qu'on puisse
pas reconstruire tant que les conditions
ne sont pas réunies et je crois
qu'effectivement la question qui va se
poser c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
cette aide l'humanitaire je crois que
aujourd'hui l'Europe n'est pas prête à
passer par Damas parce que Damas va en
faire ce qu'il veut et donc la seule
solution c'est de réouvrir quelques
postes au nord de la Syrie avec la
Turquie pour permettre la cheminement
dans la zone concernée qui est beaucoup
plus proche d'ailleurs que de Damas
puisque là les distances sont plus
importantes merci beaucoup merci à tous
c'était passionnant de de partager votre
expertise sur cette région du monde je
vais rappeler
genre le titre de votre livre le
déclassement français Élisée Quai
d'Orsay DGSE les secrets d'une guerre
d'influence stratégique publiée aux
Éditions Michel la